hypnose dieu grec du sommeil fils de Nyx
déesse de la nuit et père de Morphée
divinité des rêves mais aussi frère
jumeau de Thanatos personnification de
la mort
ouais non non stop attends non c'est
trop flippant on va laisser tomber la
mythologie en fait donc aujourd'hui on
va parler d'hypnose et vous allez voir
que ça n'a rien à voir avec le sommeil
en plus et encore moins avec la mort
mais ça j'imagine que vous en doutiez un
peu allez
[Musique]
donc l'hypnose l'hypnose médicale même
si vous avez bien le titre à quoi ça
sert comment ça marche pourquoi on s'en
sert etc j'imagine que vous posez plein
de questions sur l'hypnose médicale et
ben ça tombe bien parce que je vais y
répondre et je commence même tout de
suite avec celle là l'hypnose ça marche
vraiment bon vous doutez bien que si je
vous en parle aujourd'hui c'est que la
réponse est oui sinon j'aurais fait un
short ou une story insta et on en
parlait plus mais c'est quand même
intéressant de faire la distinction
entre différents types d'hypnose
l'hypnose de spectacle ou l'hypnose de
rue par exemple qui sont des
divertissements ou l'hypnose médicale ou
l'hypnothérapie qui sont des disciplines
de soins et c'est justement de celle là
des dernières dont on va parler
aujourd'hui non pas que les autres
soient pas intéressante mais disons que
c'est un peu moins ma partie quoi
bon mais je vous entends d'ici me
demandez et du coup Messmer c'est de
l'arnaque ou pas pour Messmer en
particulier j'en sais rien à vrai dire
mais l'hypnose de spectacle elle utilise
des techniques d'hypnose juste pas pour
faire la même chose que l'hypnose
médicale quoi mais l'hypnose médicale
c'est quoi en fait bon alors déjà si
vous discutez un petit peu avec des
hypnothérapeutes comme je l'ai fait
moi-même vous entendrez souvent dire que
c'est un pléonasme parce que par
définition l'hypnose elle est médicale
c'est pour faire des soins en tout cas
pourquoi et bah parce qu'à la base
l'hypnose elle a été inventée par
Messmer non pas celui-là justement là je
parle de Franz Anton Messmer un médecin
allemand du 18 19e siècle le vrai nom de
l'autre Messmer c'est Eric Normandin
donc en plus il y a aucun lien entre les
deux Franz sancton Messmer bon c'est un
médecin très controversé mais on
s'accorde à lui reconnaître un truc
c'est le précurseur de l'hypnose moderne
d'ailleurs en anglais hypnotisé ça se
dit mes rise bref Messmer le médecin il
l'utilisait déjà l'hypnose à la cour de
Louis XVI mais en réalité ça existe
depuis la nuit des temps ça s'appelait
juste pas comme ça mais souvent les
états de trans les exorcismes etc ça
procédé un petit peu des mêmes schémas
en tout cas ça a toujours été utilisé
pour soigner avant d'être détourné pour
en faire des spectacles mais les
puristes vous diront que l'hypnose la
vraie elle est forcément médicale et que
c'est une technique utilisée pour
obtenir un état de conscience modifié ou
plutôt un état de conscience élargi qui
permet à un professionnel de santé
d'aider son patient ou sa patiente en
modifiant la façon dont ils vivent ce
qui leur arrive et en les mettant dans
les meilleures conditions pour un soin
mais ça on va en reparler ok mais du
coup on s'en sert pourquoi bon la
première chose à laquelle vous pensez
c'est sûrement l'hypnothérapie
psychologique avisé psychothérapeutique
ah mais oui c'est exactement à ça que je
pensais enfin comment tu le sais tu m'as
hypnotisé tu as pénétré tout de suite il
y a rien de magique là-dedans personne
ne va pénétrer votre esprit ou quoi que
ce soit d'autre on va reparler de ça
pour l'instant on reste focus donc oui
l'hypnose ça peut effectivement être
utilisé dans des psychothérapies courtes
ça vous connaissez sûrement mais elle
est aussi utilisé par des médecins y
compris à l'hôpital pourquoi faire va
dans ces cas là il y a deux utilisations
principales la première c'est l'hypno
analgésie là le but de l'hypnose ça va
être de diminuer la douleur par exemple
aux urgences pour faire des points de
suture ou pour faire des soins ou des
examens douloureux aux adultes et aux
enfants ou pour des accouchements etc
etc la deuxième utilisation de l'hypnose
médicale c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'hypnosedation c'est daté ça veut dire
apaiser calmer et la sédation à
l'hôpital ça consiste à abaisser un
petit peu le niveau de vigilance de
conscience si vous voulez ça peut être
juste pour calmer quelqu'un qui est très
agité par exemple ou qui est très
stressé parce qu'on va lui faire et ça
peut aller jusqu'à l'anesthésie y
compris l'anesthésie générale pour les
opérations chirurgicales d'habitude pour
faire ça on utilise des médicaments là
l'idée c'est d'utiliser l'hypnose et on
a remarqué que ça permettait de diminuer
les doses de médicaments nécessaires
voire parfois de les remplacer
complètement alors attention on ne perd
pas des gens à cœur ouvert juste sous
hypnose ça remplace pas l'anesthésie
générale mais pervers ça peut permettre
de garder quelqu'un conscient mais de
mettre la personne dans les meilleures
conditions pour supporter l'opération
par exemple en 2014 il y a une chanteuse
professionnelle qui a été opérée d'une
tumeur à la thyroïde donc au niveau de
la gorge à l'hôpital de Créteil et pour
pas que le chirurgien risque de toucher
un truc qui pourrait briser sa carrière
bah il fallait qu'elle soit non
seulement capable de parler mais même de
chanter pendant son opération autant
dire que là du coup l'anesthésie
générale bah c'était pas possible mais
le problème c'est que c'était une
opération beaucoup trop lourde pour
qu'elle soit faite juste sous anesthésie
locale du coup l'anesthésiste qui est un
spécialiste de l'hypnose médicale et il
a complété l'anesthésie locale avec de
l'hypnose et ça a parfaitement marché et
un petit peu dans un même ordre d'idées
de garder les gens conscients pour être
sûr qu'on touche pas un truc qui craint
pendant une opération on a déjà opéré
des gens de tumeurs au niveau du cerveau
sous hypnose et l'hypnose c'est aussi de
plus en plus utilisé dans la prise en
charge de plein de trucs différents
comme le stress les troubles du sommeil
certaines douleurs chroniques des
troubles digestifs etc mais attention
les médecins ou les soignants qui
pratiquent ça
c'est des professionnels de santé qui
sont spécifiquement formés à l'hypnose
médicale et comment ça marche alors déjà
on va commencer par casser le mythe tout
de suite on ne perd pas conscience
pendant une séance d'hypnose et personne
va vous faire faire le dinosaure non
plus
même si vous tombez sur un médecin
particulièrement facétieux il pourra pas
vous faire faire ça c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche l'hypnose ça a rien de
mystique c'est juste technique en fait
ce qui va se passer c'est que par la
parole l'hypnothérapeute il va vous
amener à un état de conscience qui va
vous permettre d'avoir accès et de
contrôler un certain nombre de choses
que vous ne pouvez pas gérer en temps
normal cet état vous le connaissez en
fait c'est un petit peu le même que
celui dans lequel on est quand on se
concentre très fort sur quelque chose
vous savez quand on a cette impression
de plus vraiment être là de s'évader un
petit peu mais tout en restant conscient
et en gardant le contrôle de ce qu'on
fait bon un exemple concret pour que
vous voyez bien de quoi je parle vous
voyez quand vous lisez un livre et que
vous êtes complètement absorbé bon déjà
il peut se passer plein de trucs autour
de vous vous en rendez pas forcément
compte et si vous êtes vraiment à fond
dans l'histoire va peut-être qu'il y a
des images qui vous viennent que vous
avez l'impression de les voir peut-être
que vous avez l'impression de ressentir
des émotions voire carrément de
ressentir des sensations et des fois
même vous décrochez de la lecture parce
que votre esprit est parti ailleurs vous
avez tourné les pages mais impossible de
vous rappeler ce que vous venez de dire
bon si vous lisez jamais bah ça peut
faire ça avec la musique aussi ça peut
mettre dans ces espèces d'état de trans
calme et sereine ces espèces d'État un
peu intermédiaires ben voilà l'hypnose
l'idée c'est d'arriver à peu près là
d'être débarrassé de plein de trucs qui
nous parasitent et qui nous influence
d'habitude et d'arriver à contrôler des
choses comme la douleur par exemple
alors attention pour être très clair
l'hypnose ça ne supprime pas
complètement la douleur ça nous permet
juste de réussir à agir sur certaines de
ses composantes pour la rendre
supportable vous souvenez dans ma vidéo
sur la douleur je vous ai parlé des
composantes sensitives émotionnels
cognitives comportementale de la douleur
voilà c'est à ce niveau là qu'on arrive
à intervenir quand on est sous hypnose
notamment sur la composante émotionnelle
pour résumer un petit peu les choses en
vous parlant
l'hypnothérapeute il vous guide jusqu'à
cet état et vous aide à vous centrer sur
vous-même ce qui a deux conséquences
vous êtes plus parasiter parce qu'il se
passe à l'extérieur et vous êtes dans un
état d'hyper suggestibilité ça ça veut
dire que vous allez pouvoir vous laisser
guider par la voix de l'hypnothérapeute
et de pouvoir agir sur bah ça dépend en
fait donc la douleur le stress des
problèmes psychologiques qui sont
difficiles d'accès en temps normal etc
il y a de plus en plus d'études qui
montrent que ça marche mais à vrai dire
on manque encore un petit peu de données
scientifiques sur la façon dont ça
fonctionne concrètement comme souvent
avec le cerveau vous avez remarqué mais
en faisant des IRM à des patients des
chercheurs de l'Université de Stanford
ont quand même remarqué un truc ils ont
constaté que sous hypnose il y a des
connexions qui se font entre des zones
du cerveau qui sont pas connectées en
temps normal et c'est ce qui explique
que notre esprit est plus capable de
contrôler notre corps sous hypnose et
aussi pourquoi on arrive à se détacher
de tout ce qui est extérieur est-ce que
c'est dangereux bah non c'est comme tout
hein si c'est bien fait c'est pas
dangereux
bon non ok il y a des trucs même bien
fait c'est dangereux bon mais là déjà je
vous ai dit vous ne dormez pas pendant
une séance d'hypnose et vous restez
maître ou maîtresse de vos actes donc il
va rien vous arriver après il y a des
pratiques à risque comme l'hypnose
régressive par exemple c'est le fait de
faire remonter des vieux souvenirs du
passé qu'on avait plus ou moins effacé
là il peut y avoir une conséquence
négative qu'on appelle les faux
souvenirs pour expliquer le truc
simplement faut savoir que nos souvenirs
de base c'est une reconstruction de
notre esprit de ce qui s'est passé c'est
pas un enregistrement audio et vidéo
d'une scène c'est très subjectif mal le
risque avec ce genre de pratique c'est
d'aller déterrer un vieux souvenir à
moitié effacé et de le reconstruire avec
des bouts de trucs qu'on a sous la main
genre des rêves d'autres souvenirs des
impressions des déductions etc etc et du
coup on se retrouve avec un souvenir qui
correspond pas avec ce qui s'est passé
réellement avec toutes les conséquences
que ça peut avoir mais bon sortie de ça
l'hypnose c'est sans danger enfin
l'hypnose médicale je veux dire pour
l'hypnose de spectacle je peux pas
m'avancer un petit conseil toujours dans
le cadre de l'hypnose médicale l'hypnose
c'est un outil c'est pas une spécialité
à part entière donc pour une
psychothérapie qui utilise l'hypnose par
exemple et ben il faut aller chez un ou
une psy professionnel formée à l'hypnose
pour de la rééducation il faut aller
voir un vrai kiné formé à l'hypnose une
hypnose sédation elle doit être
pratiquée par un anesthésiste formé à
l'hypnose mais un anesthésiste à la base
quand même bon bref vous avez l'idée si
vous voulez accoucher sous hypnose de
toute façon j'imagine que vous auriez
pas l'idée d'aller voir un pot de
charcutier juste parce qu'il a fait un
petit stage pour apprendre à endormir
les gens dans la rue non bon déjà à la
base il faut être réceptif non et
comment ça se passe une séance ça marche
vraiment bien j'ai trop de questions en
fait non mais c'est normal d'avoir plein
de questions c'est vrai que c'est
fascinant quand même alors déjà tout le
monde est réceptif parce que l'état dans
lequel l'hypnothérapeute nous met c'est
un état physiologique un état qu'on a
tout et tous en nous si vous voulez
l'hypnothérapeute il nous aide juste à y
arriver à cet état et à aller chercher
les ressources pour lutter contre le
stress la douleur etc qu'on a en donc
dans l'absolu tout le monde peut y
arriver faut juste avoir un
hypnothérapeute qui nous guide avec des
techniques qui nous conviennent
d'ailleurs on peut même apprendre des
techniques d'auto-hypnose pour arriver à
cet état de conscience tout seul donc
tout le monde est réceptif plus ou moins
c'est vrai mais tout le monde est
réceptif allez hypnose médicale en tout
cas ça c'est ce que m'a dit le médecin
avec qui j'en ai parlé oui parce que
pour préparer cette vidéo j'ai discuté
avec un médecin hypnothérapeute
d'ailleurs je vais vous le présenter
bientôt pour répondre notamment aux
questions comment ça se passe une séance
est-ce que ça marche vraiment etc bon je
veux pas spoiler mais vous commencez à
me connaître un petit peu maintenant je
crois non j'aime bien expérimenter les
choses par moi-même pour mieux les
comprendre et donc pour mieux les
expliquer vous voyez venir du coup il me
reste plus qu'à trouver un truc
douloureux à me faire faire et bon du
coup pour pas rater ça tac tac
abonne-toi mets la cloche tu connais et
puis tant que tu y es abonne toi à mes
réseaux sociaux aussi parce que c'est
aussi là-bas que ça va se passer voilà
détester c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très mais alors très vite du
coup pour une nouvelle vidéo vous avez
compris
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres mettez-vous bien et
surtout prosternez-vous portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui parce que pour préparer cette vidéo
j'ai discuté avec un médecin
hypnothérapeute
tu n'as rien entendu